Selena Gomez speaks out about the  downside of dating in the public eye  while covering the September issue of  Australian vogue the 24 year old  superstar gets candid about her life  following her public breakup with Justin  Bieber Selena admits the spotlight  affects her dating life saying quote I  think people would think it's kind of  dumb to date me and continues nobody  would want to throw themselves into that  situation where it was so heightened  publicly like why would that the pop  star also says she worries her love life  overshadows her work explaining it makes  it a little harder for people to take  her seriously  but salgo insist she takes her job very  seriously explaining she fought her  label to release good for you as  revivals first single she revealed same  old love is so obvious in what it's  about it's a cycle of a very vicious  relationship I was so adamant that I  didn't want that to be my story